one of the big surprises of e3 was days
gone the game set to release exclusively
on ps4 funs drifter and bounty hunter
Deacon sent John doing his best to carve
out a life in the high desert of the
Pacific Northwest amidst a world overrun
with hordes of zombie like freaker's but
what's the history of bem studio
the devs behind the game and what have
they got to do with a small studio named
eidetic and one of the worst games ever
made
1996 was a big year the first version of
Java is released the Spice Girls
introduced the world and a nine-year-old
down to girl power and strange feelings
respectively and a company named eidetic
is helping a particular orange bobcat
make the giant leap from 2 to 3 d formed
by infocomm founders mark blanc and
michael berlin in 1993 with the express
purpose of developing sport games for
the Apple Newton they soon decided to
expand and focus on the emerging console
market their first game released on
Halloween was the horrific bubsy 3d the
game was universally panned and has gone
on to be cited as one of the worst video
games ever made the control scheme
grading music and the bland sparse
polygonal worlds all added up to a game
about which GameSpot said of all the 3d
action games out for the PlayStation
bubsy 3d is the least fun the lackluster
performance of the title and general
inexperience of the small team didn't
deter Sony who put them in touch with a
producer from nine-eight-nine Studios
who was seeking to develop an action
espionage thriller originally conceived
as just a name and a one-page synopsis
according to creative director John
Garvin Syphon Filter was another
immensely difficult project for the
burgeoning studio the game came close to
cancellation several times as the devs
didn't know anything about making
realistic shooters set in spy world the
team missed deadlines revamped mechanics
and continually changed the story
originally intended to be a science
fiction oriented story about a group of
kidnapped scientists being forced to
build a time machine the storyline was
finally changed focus on the shadowy
agency agent Gabriel Logan and his
partner as they investigate an emerging
bioterrorist threat in the form of the
Syphon Filter virus much of the story
was delivered in game in the form of
radio communications with brief between
mission cutscenes serving to highlight
the bigger more cinematic moments it
seems Sony's faith was well placed as
Syphon Filter was released in 1999 to
critical acclaim giant bombs then
GameSpot's Jeff Gerstmann said though
the game does have some minor problems
the overall experience is nothing short
of outstanding the game was praised in
particular for its AI with commendations
for how certain enemies would react to
the death of a comrade and how enemy
behaviour would change each time a level
was played sometimes in the form of
taking cover or carrying different
weapons one particular standout weapon
was the Taser when fired at an enemy the
camera would reposition to focus on the
victim as they arrived in agony and if
the trigger was held long enough they'd
eventually burst into flames
Syphon Filter exceeded the expectations
of both stone
and eidetic selling over 1 million units
in its first year and work immediately
began on a sequel released in 2000
Syphon Filter 2 saw the first game story
expanded with liberal use of between
mission cutscenes causing the game to be
released across two discs but the
sequels biggest change was the inclusion
of two players with screen deathmatch
while rudimentary by today's standards
it stood out at release thanks to
brilliant level design including secret
areas to get the drop on your opponent
and impressive arsenal of weapons and a
satisfying shooting and movement from
the single-player experience
shortly after Syphon Filter 2 was
released Sony acquired eidetic and the
company was renamed bench studios the
newly renamed studio then set about
releasing another four Syphon Filter
games
Syphon Filter 3 for ps1 Syphon Filter
the Omega strain for ps2 and Syphon
Filter Dark Mirror and Logan shadow for
the PSP and ps2 after 11 years with
Syphon Filter it was time for Sony Ben
to branch out and develop games for a
new franchise then decided to make a
demo for what they had in mind and after
showing it to Sony worldwide studios in
insomniac they were approved to begin
development on their next project
resistance retribution for the PSP
building on the existing resistance
franchise retribution deviated from the
series trademark first-person view to
deliver a third-person action game on a
scale never before seen on a portable
device Sony been cleverly tackled one of
the shortcomings of Sony's first
handheld the absence of a second stick
for aiming by utilizing a bracketed auto
aiming area in the middle of the screen
any targets that fell within the defined
area could be Auto targeted with the
push of a button retribution also
introduced infected mode it was possible
to infect a copy of retribution with the
Chimera virus using a ps3 copy of
resistance to the mode unlocked several
new mechanics such as regenerating
health increased lung capacity in order
to reach secret areas new weapons and
infected Intel's after proving their
success with another Studios franchise
Sony band went after the Mario of
PlayStation the Sonic of Sony the super
everyman himself
Nathan Drake Bend went through several
versions for their Uncharted game for
the then unannounced PlayStation Vita
one idea would have seen players begin
as a college aged rake drifting his
fellow students on campus and another in
a huge departure for the franchise was
going to go open-world
players would have been able to move
freely between their base camp where
they could interact with supporting
characters like Elena and Sully and
various ruin sites to battle mercenaries
and local drug running thugs for ancient
artifacts finally they settled on a
prequel to uncharted drake's Fortune
titled
uncharted golden Abyss wherein nate is
hired by his old friend jason dante to
uncover secrets and treasures in the
Central American jungle utilizing some
of the Vedas unique functionality
players were able to take charcoal
rubbings using the front touch screen
uncover hidden messages by holding their
system up to a bright light and aim
weapons and the in-game SLR camera using
the Vita's gyro the game launched
alongside the Vita in 2011 and went on
to sell 1.7 million copies worldwide it
proved that triple-a game experiences
usually associated with home consoles
were capable on a portable system at the
conclusion of their time with uncharted
Sony Ben went dark rumors swirled online
as to what they were working on in 2014
a leak purported to show concept art
from a work-in-progress open-world
horror game some of the art showed
characters wearing a very familiar white
and black headset the Ben logo fades
under the screen at Sony's e3 conference
days gone kicks off the conference's
trailer block with an affecting human
look at its tortured protagonists and
post-apocalyptic world before closing
out Sony's conference with a six minute
gameplay presentation highlighting the
impressive freak awards and
environmental gameplay after five years
of silence bender back and from the
looks of it they're coming back bigger
than they've ever been before so that's
a brief --is-- history of Sony Bend
have you checked out any of their games
over the years and what do you think of
what we've seen up days gone make sure
to let us know in the comments and for
more on Days gone keep it parked at
GameSpot